no way from Hamburg is asking how the
decisions were making here right now and
also remembered a decade or century from
now of course the honest answer is we
don't know but the hope is so there are
decisions being made these days that are
going to help build an infrastructure
for the new world my fear being here in
Davos is that I'm among more disrupted
the disruptors their disruptors around
there are technologists and other people
but I think what we see happening
represented in the world by the folks
who are here in Davos is that major
institutions are being threatened by the
internet networks new opportunities
cross-border collaboration and it's
going to change the definition of
companies and governments and industries
and education and it's a time of
incredible disruption and that
disruption will not erupt here from
dummies so the question is the leaders
who are here will they try to resist
that disruption which many will will
they recognize it and try to be smart
about and finally the opportunity in it
or will they join it I hope that this
year in future years you'll find people
who will join the disruption by finding
the opportunity